il y a quatre cents ans jean baptiste
poquelin voit le jour à paris sur scène
il deviendra molière l'un des plus
grands hommes des théâtres français
cette oeuvre est en maquette en volume
et à l'échelle de la tentative de
reconstitution du décor du malade
imaginaire conforme à ce qu'on sait de
la création par molière en février 1673
cette maquette est l'une des 400 oeuvres
de l'exposition molière la fabrique
d'une gloire nationale elle investit à
partir du 15 janvier l'espace richaud de
la ville de versailles dans cette
exposition vous pourrez voir des
éléments patrimoniaux des grandes
peintures officielle des sculptures des
gravures quelques documents étaient
authentiques notamment une ordonnance
signée par le roi donnant un molière
l'exclusivité de l'exploitation d'une de
ses pièces le malade imaginaire ce n'est
donc pas par hasard que versailles a
choisi d'accueillir cet événement
molière a joué plusieurs de ses pièces
dans les jardins du château il était
proche de la cour et notamment du
roi-soleil tels rapports de confiance
entre molière et le roi louis xiv qu'un
moment il y avait une sorte
d'exclusivité était un train quatre
siècles nous sépare de son oeuvre
pourtant le dramaturge et toujours sur
le devant de la scène il est devenu un
véritable mythe repris au théâtre mais
aussi au cinéma ou en dessin on a voulu
donner toute leur place aussi à des
oeuvres contemporaines actuelle un
graffiti de rues représentant un village
de molière un roman graphique une bande
dessinée du cinéma de façon à montrer
que molière est toujours vivant qu'il
est parmi nous et qu'il reste une source
très féconde d'inspiration non seulement
au théâtre mais également dans toutes
sortes de mode d'expression artistique
de culture même très populaire
l'exposition prendra fin le 17 avril
prochain elle laissera place en juin au
mois molière le festival de théâtre et
de musique à versailles